what was your inspiration for creating
the society of faceless men and was
there anything in history that inspired
it or was it just a plot thing with aria
that you thought about a personal
inspiration my original inspiration for
creating the faceless men I don't know I
you know it's a common trope of fantasy
that you have like the guild of
assassins I was hardly the first one to
invent the guild of assassins
you know that's largely a fantasy trope
there's not much evidence for that in
history well the one evidence is you did
actually have a group called the
assassins who were in the Middle East
and there was a guy called the old man
in the mountain who would send forth his
assassins to to kill people in the
Middle East where they'd been killing
people for many many centuries but they
were not like fantasy guilds of sessions
so I decided to put my own spin on it
you know I actually came up with several
different guilds of the sessions not
only the faceless men but the sorrowful
men and all that and there's a little
bit in there in the in the philosophy of
the faceless men that is you know there
in some senses there are difficult and
there it's a religious basis which I
kind of thought about and extrapolated
from that I'm surprised we don't have
more death cults in the real world
because it just seems to me that if
you're gonna ever worship something
death is a pretty good thing because you
know like we have all these religions
that promise you life everlasting
no that never deliver on it
everybody and all of the religions that
I promise you worth dives anyway so the
death cult is the one that wins
the death cult can really deliver death
they come and worship with us and you
will die well so what the hell so I took
with that and is that Westeros I'm here
and well that would be telling
but I think there's a good chance yes so
whenever I first read your series I of
course I'm sided with Daenerys since she
has lain originally but I'm a history
teacher and I'm teaching my students
about the westward expansion and as I'm
teaching them about how the view that
American citizens to vote early on I'm
siding with us because we were able to
use brute force and if ever when's the
land is the original ownership so my
question is is it the peat with European
not trying to get your opinion on how
the story will end but even with that
and historically is it the person who
dominates it and you would root for sirs
the people who originally family and
home ownership
well you know human beings through all
of history have been trying to sort this
out who has to write to the land I mean
how far back the land claims go you know
you go far enough back and all the lands
wouldn't the end at door man and you
know then he gets wiped out by by
cro-magnon and or in Tabriz with
cro-magnon theories have now diverged on
that link and then civilizations come
and go I mean you look at the British
Isles and you know in history historical
terms you had two picks in the Scots
there they're originally in the Celts
you might even have older groups than
that if you believe the legends that -
offered - Dinan and the furball were
based on natural peoples who existed
there before the Celtic game but then
after the Celts kind of the Romans come
in and they have their thing and they
leave their deposits and then after the
Romans you get the angles and the Saxons
and after the angles in sections you get
the Normans and the Vikings come in the
Danes they have a influence they get a
few kings so history is history is
written in blood and the land doesn't
belong to anyone except who takes it and
what they do with the preceding
inhabitants if there's one thing history
is taught us it's that I would like to
think that that Gordie Dixon was right
and then a moral evolution has gone then
that you know 100 years 200 years 500
years we'll we will arrive at the point
where history is no longer written in
blood but it is
you know written in an ink or
phosphorous on a computer screen again
and where we are all Terrans and you
know some of us may be well you look at
these DNA tests on a specially about
confident we're all mongrels anyway we
just sometimes don't like to admit it to
to each other Ellis mutts
we're mutts the human races months and
we need to become more months all these
you know cries to France for the French
Germans for the Germans America for the
Americans
all of these are throwbacks atavistic
xenophobic things fear of the other fear
of differences and hopefully eventually
we'll leave this all behind and I think
we will eventually because the more
people live together they more they [ __ ]
with each other and and children are
born and all the interbreeding occurs
whether we pass laws against the
verified by it and and the culprit
traditions happen and people move into
your neighborhoods and found a new
restaurant and you discover you like
that food then you meet the owners and
their children go to school with your
children and that's all everything comes
together all these things and I think
that's the future there even a Westeros
of course I've tried to indicate a sort
of British history with the Westeros I
mean you have two children a forest
first and they're the only people there
and they really are at the state's
pieces and the Giants who are another
distinct species and then human beings
come in the first men and of course it's
written in blood so there's a lot of war
to kill each other they form a treaty
but then here comes another invasion
with the Andals coming in and
you know eventually the targaryen
arrived with their dragons having a
dragon really helps things thank you
[Applause]
seems like a lot of the stories are very
clearly pointing at different society
issues and I wondered if you're gonna do
any more that's it we're gonna see more
of him you know I would like I have
ideas for another twenty tough stories
I'm kind of busy with this Ice and Fire
the name right now I don't know when
I'll get around to writing them at some
point sure even that at one point in
contract for a second Toughbook and the
first question was called tough waging
and as next one's gonna be called twice
as tough but I I never wrote the stories
and I got involved this other stuff and
I eventually bought out the contractor
by painting publisher back but get out
there someday I'd love to do that he was
a fun fun character to write and those
stories were kind of fun they're a
little lighter than most of my stuff
well they're not really a rock there are
like the entire worlds that are just for
written stuff for but it's interesting
what's considered light entertainment
and most not considered light
entertainment
I've I've thought about that sometimes
you know give you kill one character and
that the people know and love and you
get this reputation for being bloody but
you wipe out millions of people and no
one blinks
you know it's like we look at
Schindler's List as this incredibly dark
and weird being film about the Holocaust
and you know we see people die you know
who were killed who was shot and all
that and we consider star wars the light
long but I can storage they blow up the
entire planet of alderaan like we've got
a story go oh I just felt a great
disturbance in the forest you know fifty
billion people have just been snuffed
out and what's the next act okay so it's
it's odd the way you know one death is a
tragedy and fifty billion deaths or a
statistic as I think someone will say so
there are horrible things that happen in
tough stories but they're in the realm
of statistics thank you